je sais que ton père ne t'a pas donner
une enfance normale n'est tué entre au
lycée aujourd'hui c'est l'occasion de
prendre un nouveau départ
remets moi d'essayer de vivre comme une
jeune fille normale
promis si je mange car leurs modèles au
travail
van dyck si c'est pas toi
[Musique]
quatre adversaires
impossible de fuir
ah ah
ça va chier bande d'enculés
t'en a pas marre de bosser tout seul
t'as pas envie d'aller plus loin de
faire partie d'une équipe ensemble on
peut frapper plus fort
ça dit joindre à nos questions en tête
essayez de vous éclater c'est vrai quoi
sinon je vois pas l'intérêt
[Musique]
j'ai pas besoin de passer des quatre
prochaines années de ma vie me demandez
qui je suis vraiment
dieu que je vais sait déjà
je suis gay
[Applaudissements]
taquet les greens peut-être que j'ai de
foot mon pied dans ta chatte